so it's Friday night I'm getting ready
to go out I'm feeling kind but before I
go out I got a free game and the only
way I pre-game is with which
an ice cold Bud Light is so good
Lord that was the most disturbing cold
open we've ever done I suppose I owe you
an apology and we're only 10 seconds
into the program I'm Dave Rubin this is
the Reuben report it's May 24 2023 we're
live streaming as always on Rumble
YouTube and locals if you haven't joined
us at locals yet do it
come on Reuben report.locals.com however
in full disclosure there will be no post
game show today I've got a thing trust
me good reasons I'll get into them uh
next week but uh we got a good show for
you today uh you know people often ask
me Dave what do you do in your free time
we know you're uh focused on the program
and you must devote all of your life to
politics and everything else but every
now and again uh when it's late night
and I have a little tequila and I'm
sitting on the couch and the kids are
asleep I'm flipping through YouTube or
Rumble whatever it might be and I watch
a lot of old television I think there's
something about old TV it reminds me of
something perhaps something that I could
help Usher a Resurgence of in our
quasi-modern time so to speak and I
watch a lot of the old Johnny Carson
Tonight Show and I saw something related
to Budweiser that is so relative to
what's going on these days that we're
gonna compare and contrast Budweiser
from 1975 to Bud Light in 2023 and a
couple other cultural things related to
Canada Italy and more and then we've got
a Ruben report.locals.com Community Q a
and before we get to that let me talk to
you about ramp do you feel like your
finance software isn't cutting it do you
want the latest and greatest in
financial software to simply spend help
you save time and keep you from getting
trapped in busy work check out ramp ramp
is the corporate card and expense
management software designed to help you
save time and put money back in the
pocket in your pocket ramp gives Finance
teams unprecedented control and insight
into company spend with ramp you're able
to issue cards to every employee with
limits and restrictions and automate
expense reporting so you can stop
wasting time at the end of every month
ramps accounting software automatically
collects receipts and categorizes your
expenses in real time so you don't have
to you'll never have to chase down a
receipt again and your employees will no
longer spend hours submitting expense
reports the time you'll save each month
on employee expenses will allow you to
close your books eight times faster ramp
saves you money businesses that use rap
save an average of 3.5 percent in the
first year and now get 250 when you join
ramp just go to ramp.com Reuben that's
ramp.com reuben ramp.com reuben and now
back to me okay so you guys know about
all this craziness related to uh
wokeness infecting all of our
institutions and destroying pretty much
everything whether it's educational
institutions political institutions
corporate institutions entertainment
institutions beer institutions like
Budweiser the apparent beer of Bud Light
owned by Anheuser-Busch of course and
what sparked much of the latest brouhaha
was that Bud Light sponsored Dylan
Mulvaney this is a dude dressed as a
chick who got his face on a can of beer
and it is almost completely destroyed
the Bud Light brand you may remember
this and then you'll see why I'm showing
it to you
hi impressive carrying skills right I
got some Bud Lights for us so I kept
hearing about this thing called March
Madness and I thought we were all just
having a hectic month but it turns out
it has something to do with sports and
I'm not sure exactly which sport but
either way it's a cause to celebrate
this month I celebrated my day 365 a
Womanhood and Bud Light Sent Me possibly
the best gift ever a can with my face on
it check out my Instagram story to see
how you can enjoy March Madness with Bud
Light and maybe win some money too love
ya
don't love you back uh okay you guys
know the Fallout from this thing Bud
Light is stuck on shelves Anheuser-Busch
offered like this half-assed apology I
think they like suspended or slightly
removed with pay the woman who was in
charge of this they were embarrassed by
their own customers I mean just an
absolute catastrophic mess for the
company and I have to say it's good to
see because one way you can push back
against this nonsense is with your
dollars now you might be going Dave why
are you showing me this this thing
happened you know a month ago six weeks
ago whatever it might be there is a
reason because at night I do watch I
usually watch old Carson tonight shows
sometimes I watch Seinfeld I watch old
Simpsons episodes things like that but I
was watching a Johnny Carson Tonight
Show last night with it was a guest host
so it wasn't Carson hosting it was Joey
Bishop was guest hosting this has got to
be around 1975 and the guests the reason
I was watching this particular episode
were Frank Sinatra and uh Dean Martin
and I love Sinatra and I love Dean and I
love them together they used to get up
there and they'd be drinking and it was
unscripted and it was Politically
Incorrect and just absolutely beautiful
anyway they go to Commercial and they
have Ed McMahon doing a Budweiser
commercial sort of in studio watch this
and just see how in 40 plus years how
things have changed so drastically it's
this is just great watch this
[Music]
[Applause]
and now here speaking in round figures
for the king of beers is Ed McMahon
did you ever think about all the
sandwiches that are consumed across the
country during just one evening's
Tonight Show
for example there are thousands of
loaves of bread
hundreds of slices of cold cuts
jar after jar of mustard
actually tons and tons of pickles
and when all those sandwiches are
enjoyed
here's a safe bet on what's being
enjoyed right along with them
that of course would be Budweiser but is
the largest selling beer in the world
here's the beard that makes it Mighty
clear what taste is all about so raise
your Stein at the friendly sign but
wiser king of beer
if you're planning an icebox raid
tonight
go right ahead and pour yourself a
Budweiser to go right along with that
sandwich
it could possibly cost a little more
but as the echo says it's that Budweiser
taste that makes it worth it it is worth
it
it's Budweiser
I mean isn't that something as Ed
McMahon is kind of laughing through it
this is the way they used to do
advertising on television they've
actually brought that method back a
little bit in the last couple years
where hosts do those sort of reads it's
not too far from the type of reads we do
here but isn't it something he's selling
beer or Budweiser is selling beer
because it tastes good right that's why
they're trying to get you to buy the
beer it tastes good and he's saying it
might cost you a little bit more but it
tastes good so it's worth it you might
enjoy it when you're watching a game and
eating a sandwich with a giant vat of
mustard it was an awful lot of mustard
how different in 40 something years I'm
not even telling you that was the
greatest commercial ever or any or how
marketing was or anything but just the
simple fact that back then all the
Budweiser wanted to do with cell beer
and they thought that was an effective
way of doing it on The Tonight Show with
that McMahon the sidekick the Johnny
Carson and we're going to do these live
reads and not pandering to an audience
that doesn't even drink their beer
actually going to the people who might
drink it saying this is why you're gonna
like it this is why you're gonna pay
your hard-earned dollars for it and that
is just so starkly different than what
has happened you know 40 plus years
later and Bud Light and Budweiser and
Anheuser-Busch the entire family is
paying the price for it and anyway I
just saw last night and I thought you
guys would would find it interesting and
it does sort of link to the other uh
story that I wanted to do on today's
show because uh you know this Justin
Trudeau fella you know him up in Canada
this very sort of asexual but I wear
nice socks as I oppress women and arrest
people and close their bank accounts
guy well he was at the G7 meeting and he
was sitting across from Italy's new
prime minister Georgia Maloney and you
might know Georgia Maloney we've played
a couple videos of her she has come into
Italy and she is turning it around they
are not dealing with any of this woke
nonsense she is fighting to protect her
country's border and culture and uh it's
it's working it's actually working so of
course mainstream media is calling her a
fascist and all that and here's Justin
Trudeau trying to uh trying to well I
was going to say manhandle trying to do
whatever it is that he does uh beat her
over the head with his LGBT nonsense
obviously uh Canada is concerned about
some of the uh some of the positionings
that Italy is taking in terms of the
LGBT rights but I look forward to
talking with you about that because
we're here at the G7 as as a assembly of
countries that uh that are promoting the
kinds of strong values and Democratic
principles that the world needs and I I
always look forward to those
conversations with you God isn't he just
gross lecturing another world leader
about what she's doing related to LGBT
rights now to be clear Italy has done
nothing to LGBT rights they've done
something sort of similar to what's
going on here in Florida and a couple
other red states where they don't want
some of this stuff being pushed on
children and in school but they have not
taken away gay people's rights or
anything else but you see the way he
can't even look at her she's got her
legs crossed directly at him looking at
him the entire time he can't even look
at her and I would connect this to a bit
of what we've talked about a bunch over
the last couple months this sort of idea
that Nations have a right to decide what
they want to do I would not be for any
nation that wanted to punish or imprison
or whatever it's gay people or it's or
it's other minorities or whatever else
right I believe that there are Universal
human rights but every nation can decide
what it wants to teach its people how it
wants to protect its borders and
everything else and that's what the the
globalists fear the most the globalists
want one world government and everybody
will be controlled beneath that what we
should want are strong independent
states that do what they want that
hopefully is in conjunction with freeing
as many of their people as possible so
that they can prosper and do what they
want with their lives and then maintain
their cultural traditions and their
languages and foods and music and all of
that stuff and then you can figure out
where to work together when you have
common interests as opposed to just
being told what to do what you should do
by say Klaus Schwab that would be bad
Italy is not just protecting its culture
it's also protecting the way that it
eats check this out from Forbes Italy
will ban the sale of lab-grown meat and
other synthetic Foods choosing Heritage
natural over Laboratories fake anyone
who violates this will face fines up to
000 Lira again I thought this was
interesting not that the the meat versus
not meat okay is what it is but they're
saying hey we don't have to do this in
the name of climate we don't it we're
Italian we love good food Manja
everybody right like we don't have to go
down this path now they're banning it
you might say that that's a bit extreme
Perhaps it is but they're doing what
they think is right and of course the
whole world and the G7 and the
globalists and everything they're very
angry at them because they want them to
cut back on meat and eat bugs like the
rest of you will be eating bugs as
you're in Mark Zuckerberg's uh metaverse
um but another thing going on in Italy
is this climate act this is this is
really wild and it shows you how out of
control these people are climate
activists you may have seen this uh
jumped into Rome's Trevi Fountain which
is a legendary found in Rome I've been
there and they poured black diluted
chemicals in the water to protest
climate change I don't think Maloney is
going to stand for this climate
activists turn the Blue Waters of the
famous Trevi Fountain Black by dumping
charcoal into it the protest was aimed
at the Italian government and its use of
fossil fuels as historic floods ravaged
parts of the country all all of the
activists were arrested officials say
they'll now have to drain the fountain
entirely throwing out 66 000 gallons of
water
and disappointing a lot of tourists you
see how the media even frames it that
it's somehow the drought and now the
floods and that that somehow has to do
with fossil fuels there's just no
evidence of any of this nonsense but
anyway I bring all of these things up
whether it's the Budweiser thing or
Italy Banning these meats it's like
everybody which what direction are we
going in are we going in a direction
where we're more mature where we sell
products to people for good reasons
where we look at our citizens and we
defend what it is they want or whether
we're going to go all in and we're going
to ruin all of our Fountains at our
historical monuments and whether we're
going to trash all of our beers and
whatever else we drink and all of that
stuff
that question remains to be seen let's
talk about Birch gold group and then
we'll get to the Reuben report Community
Q a uh president Trump recently issued a
warning from his Mar-A-Lago home quote
our currency is crashing and will soon
no longer be the world standard which
will be our greatest defeat frankly in
200 years there are reasons the central
banks are dumping the dollar inflation
deficit spending and our insurmountable
national debt fact is guys there's one
asset that has withstood famine Wars and
political and economic upheaval dating
back to Biblical times yeah you guessed
it gold and you can own it in a tax
sheltered retirement account with the
help of Birch gold that's right Birch
gold will help you convert an existing
Ira or 401K maybe from a previous
employer into an IRA in gold and the
best part you don't pay a penny out of
pocket just visit birchgold.com Dave for
your free info kit that'll hold your
hand through the entire process think
about this when currencies fail gold is
a safe haven how much more time does the
Dollar have I don't know protect your
savings with gold like I did Virgil gold
has an A plus rating with the Better
Business Bureau and thousands of happy
customers visit birchgold.com Dave to
get your free info kit on gold again
visit birchgold.com Dave and now back to
me okay Reuben report.locals.com
Community Q a here we go prosky says do
you think that Nikki Haley Vivek Mike
Pence and Trump are all sticking up for
Disney because maybe if they don't other
corporations won't fund their
presidential campaign it's obvious to me
that Governor DeSantis is a threat to
them but I wonder if that's why or if
they're just as ignorant to what
governor DeSantis has truly done to
Disney and the State of Florida and as
oh as I always say thank you for what
you do you're quite welcome and I'm glad
you're part of the community
um I don't think it's ignorance I don't
think that their miscalculation on this
is ignorance you can't tell me honestly
that vivec and Nikki Haley don't know
what they're saying right they're doing
this because they think this is a way to
get DeSantis it's I and I really hate
that sort of political posturing it's
like you can't say you're against woke
and then when the one guy uh does
something about woke like the most
damaging thing to woke that's possible
uh he actually affects their their
bottom line which maybe could turn
around a giant corporation that every
kid watches all their programming and
everything else if that's the guy you're
going after you're making a real mistake
so I don't think they're ignorant I
think it's probably somewhat related to
donations I try not to go too far down
that road with people because I don't
want to think that look people get money
in campaigns from all sorts of people I
don't think everything is exactly quid
pro quo but there is some level of that
for sure so it probably has something to
do with donations but it mostly has to
do with they're going after the guy who
is who I really believe is number one
right now I don't think it's Trump which
is why everyone is going after Trump I
think after DeSantis announces you're
going to see some real shifts in things
it may not bear out in the polls
immediately
um but we know that there's a huge
amount I mean this is this is poll after
poll shows this there's a huge amount of
soft support for Trump meaning Trump's
got that 30 base no matter what and that
may get him over the finish line for
sure but there's about 70 percent of
Republicans that are undecided they are
willing to look in a different direction
and sometimes you wait for the guy to
freaking jump in so I think it's
somewhat cynical what they're all doing
and DeSantis has done the right thing
and I think when people do the right
thing you gotta you gotta help them
along the way Amy says what was the
total banana yield from your tree and
what are you going to do or make with
them so we got we'll throw a picture up
of our bananas we have a banana tree uh
in the backyard and you know banana
trees uh this time of year we got about
three bunches right now each Bunch how
many bananas on a banana Bunch can we
google that I guess there's got to be
about
60 bananas on a banana Bunch something
like that so we've got a lot of bananas
here and we've got another Bunch that's
about to come down and then you know I
didn't know this about the banana tree
but when that stock goes gives you the
banana Bunch the stock basically dies so
you cut it out and then another one just
starts growing almost immediately so
we're already growing for what will be
the bananas of next year uh I am told
that there are 200 bananas in a bunch
and a cluster of bananas is 10 to 20
bananas uh yeah so we've got an awful
lot of bananas here David's been making
some banana ice cream we've been giving
the kids a little banana I've been
having a banana each morning would you
guys like some bananas
Phoenix's girlfriend just made banana
bread with other bananas actually so I'm
going to give you some bananas to leave
with we'll have some more banana bread
it's been a lot of bananas around here
and I say bananas all the time so it's
very fitting uh Communist Cat says have
you seen the birth Gap birth rate
documentary and what are your thoughts
would you be interested in covering it
on the show I have not seen the document
documentary yet a few people have
mentioned it to me uh it was one of the
things that came up repeatedly when I
was in Israel and Hungary you know
Israel and Hungary which are you know
Western nations in the way that they
behave they have strong birth rates
right now a lot of Western Nations do
not Japan for example
um is basically facing population
collapse that people are having children
much older so you know back in the day
if you think about if you're about my
age mid-40s your grandparents usually
had kids 18 19 20 21. now people aren't
having kids into their late 20s even 30s
I I mean I didn't become a father until
46. uh that then changes the replacement
rate and all of those things so I am
interested in this and why certain
nations are doing it right and what are
the incentives that government can give
so that you will have a big family which
um I can tell you as a new father is
probably the most rewarding thing that
you could do we can save America 2024
says Dave Rubin Clan and Community what
do you all think about the way we are
selling missiles like candy when the
Democrats are literally breaking our
backs over climate change rush to do
electric cars cows are killing the ozone
wanting us to eat fake food gas prices
are so high people are more worried
about gas than buying food how in the
world is that good for climate change
I think you're on to something you know
look at the end of the day putting red
blue Democrat Republican aside war is
seemingly always good for business
that's why it's almost like you know we
wrapped up that Afghanistan war that
nobody knew why we were there for 20
some odd years even though 911 was more
guys in Saudi Arabia but we went to the
war okay we're going to attack the
Taliban beat them there so they don't
come here all the money all of the gold
all of the the fruits of it we left most
of the stuff there we then buy more
stuff we shoot missiles all over the
place
war is good for business it's it's an
unfortunate reality but uh yes you would
think I suppose that the people maybe
who are so screaming all the time about
climate change would be upset that
there's so much stuff blowing up uh
relative to Ukraine and we should be
scaling that back but uh you know logic
isn't the best for these people uh
Elizabeth says what do you make of
trigonometry having their bank account
closed do you think it was an error or
political retaliation I'm leaning
towards retaliation so uh trigonometry
which is hosted by Constantine kissing
and he's got a uh what's the other guy's
name on the podcast uh Francis
we'll get it Francis something or other
of a Constantine I had on the show a
couple weeks back great guys over in the
UK
um their bank account the show's bank
account was closed and it does seem like
it had some sort of political bent the
bank that they were with had this entire
diversity equity and inclusion thing
it's Francis Foster is his name
um so it does seem that there's a
political event and it does seem like
look de-banking
Banks just getting together and
basically saying these types of people
we will not work with whether it's
because of political views their views
on guns they said something
inappropriate blah blah blah this is a
seriously dangerous escalation in the
next version of all this right what
happened a year ago with the Canadian
truckers they were going to close bank
accounts you wouldn't be able to move
money all of these things they were
going to try to track all of your
transfers which they're probably doing
to all of us as is
um this is why I say we need a parallel
economy when it comes to everything it's
not just that Rumble is building the
alternative to Amazon AWS Amazon web
services and an alternative to YouTube
we need alternative payment processors
which we are working on we need
alternative email right Gmail they're
scanning all your emails we all know all
of this stuff so my guess is in this
case this was not an accident it
probably was quite direct I don't know
what the subsequent Fallout has been on
that we'll check on that Florida man
Chuck says do you think the
non-democrats will be able to Rally
behind a single candidate or do you
think things will be divided between
Trump and DeSantis I feel like if we
even have 51 percent of the votes if
it's split between two candidates the
American people lose again look
obviously you guys know my feelings
about the Trump DeSantis situation and
having voted for Trump and basically
liking Trump and maybe I'll vote for him
again if this had this thing doesn't
work out DeSantis obviously seems like
the better choice he's the guy that the
crossover people can come to as I always
say think of all of the family members
all of the friends all the people you
heard on the media say I like Trump I
like the policies I just don't like him
I don't like grabbing by the I
don't like the Twitter stuff with
DeSantis you have all that and you have
more effective policies and you have
someone far younger and far more
disciplined and he's got young kids and
a good family and all of those things
I'm not saying Trump doesn't have a good
family you get it though so he's the guy
that could bring like what let's put it
this way
the the Bill Maher types and I get it
Bill Maher's never going to get there he
has too much invested in his career as
the liberal or whatever it'll be and
he'll be rally the day before the
election after he'll he's railed against
woke for two more years the day before
the election he'll be telling people to
vote for the Democrat to save democracy
okay fine but that set of people who are
the people that can move the people who
have woke up to the evils of the
Democrat Party but they're still nervous
about Republicans
DeSantis is the crossover guy the Elon
Musk types right The Joe Rogan Elon Musk
obviously will vote for d for DeSantis
Joe Rogan obviously will vote for
DeSantis I don't know that either one of
them would vote for Trump I don't think
they would I don't think they did last
time so this is the chance this is the
great chance America has to reset this
thing and I hope people see that uh
William says although I like Trump as
president and he might be a great
president again it does seem slash feel
to me that he will not be able to get
himself reelected how is he going to get
new votes or the neutral or independent
votes for example a Joe Rogan or Elon
Musk mode I just can't see him getting
new or more votes you see this is proof
that I take these questions on the Fly I
mean I basically just answered that
um but I would say to answer your your
direct
questionnaire where are the new Trump
voters let's say let's if we all agree
basically that you that DeSantis can get
some new guys the elons the Joes and the
people that would come with that where
is it that Trump could get new voters
now you could definitely see a certain
amount of trump people being like I've
just had it I don't want to do this
again the election stuff and the fraud
and the name calling and going after
descendants you could see a certain
amount of people just being like I'm not
going to do it again like I did it it
was fun I'm just not going to do it so
that that would cause less votes where
is the new Trump voter is it is it the
kid who just now can get can vote for
the first time who suddenly is like yes
I do love Trump like that doesn't seem
real is it someone that's so disgusted
by Joe Biden that they're going to move
to Trump
I don't think so so it's just reality
it's just reality Bo Jackson is it the
original Bo Jackson says uh what's up
Dave thank you for all the content and
you and your team continue to produce as
a former question mark stand up what's
your favorite joke that you found breaks
the ice to either start your set or gain
the audience back if things aren't going
that well on stage I have to tell you uh
you know I've never bombed that much I
really didn't like every comic has
bombed for sure like without question uh
except for one little period of my
career it was actually right when I sort
of came out publicly and I was shifting
my stand up a little bit and you know I
I knew it wasn't going to work and it
wasn't really what I wanted to talk
about and you know to to quote uh Homer
Simpson Marge I like my beers cold and
my homosexuals flaming that's what Homer
said uh that's what stand-up audiences
wanted so when I came out I was still
who I was and I was talking about this
stuff that didn't Jive for the audiences
they were used to over the top gay guys
oh my God
so that was really the only time I kind
of struggled but I you know it's simple
if if the joke just flops literally a
kind of dead pen
is this thing on it works it always
works it's just one of those things that
always works but I was always messing
around for any of you that have seen me
on book tours or any of the other things
that I've done in the last couple years
I was always kind of messing around with
the crowd more and playing with what was
going on in that room as opposed to
being super scripted so you know there
were some Comics that they can't improv
their way out of a wet paper bag you
know so they can only do jokes they
can't go off script so if the joke's not
working and now two jokes don't work it
out three jokes don't work they they
can't do anything back out of that I
never really had that issue because I
was always just kind of bobbing and
weaving my way through it uh Lloyd what
do you think of the NAACP issuing a
travel advisory for Florida have they
gone far beyond their original focus on
civil rights yes look much like the ADL
the Anti-Defamation League much like
glad gays lesbians against
yeah something something these
organizations once you once you
accomplish what you want in terms of
civil rights we want to make sure women
can vote we want to make sure gay people
can get married we want to make sure
black people can vote whatever whatever
those things are to accomplish equality
once you've done that you really should
close up shop but non-profits and any
organization doesn't want to close oh
we've done everything guys let's have
that final dinner we did everything we
want to do no you got to go find more
problems as Chris Rock says I quote it
all the time the cops need a certain
amount of crime so they could have
closed up shop right there's no reason
it's not to say that racism doesn't
exist we all know this of course racism
exists there are going to be some
racists it's just how it is there always
have been there always will be and if
you think you can eliminate racism
you're gonna have to kill a lot of
people
uh but these organizations have gone
well past their mandate this this
Florida thing is so profoundly
ridiculous and all it does is is serve
the people who want everyone to be
divided by race anyone watching this
right now
I have no doubt we have some black
viewers you're welcome here in Florida
and I would say just like white people
you will flourish here because we have
no state income tax we have safe roads
and safe cities everyone is flourishing
down here the weather is great and uh
and the mosquitoes you can spray for
them so it's all good Mike says DeSantis
has accomplished a lot but is there a
chance you could support Elder in a
primary I mean look I love and adore
Larry as we talked about on the show
yesterday he's been so integral in my
political Evolution and and so many
things connected to my life and just the
whole thing
um I will I'm certainly not going to
badmouth them I I want him to stay in
the race as long as possible and all of
that stuff I think it is great that
Larry will be on stage to get some of
his ideas out there I think you know
he's going to have trouble fundraising
because I don't think people really
think he's going to be president so you
know he'll get to a debate or two and
then eventually when the money runs out
you're just kind of you you are where
you are and Larry if you're watching
this you know how I feel about you so
this is not going after you in any way
um I think I think he would be make a
great addition to any Administration
etc etc maybe even a VP
um but just clearly I think I think this
is DeSantis chance and so I'll support
Larry however I can in terms of the
ideas and all of those things but
obviously in terms of support who I
think is the next president you guys got
it uh Spike says Trump may be
entertaining but his strategy is to be
the loudest on the potential stage so
the primary really looks like it'll be
the noisy one versus any number of
quality and good policy making
candidates so do you think it'll roll
that way look yeah basically right like
that's why the Trump thing has been so
frustrating to me personally because I
really I mean just go back to my videos
of two three months ago I really did not
want to have to go after Trump and I
really did not want Trump to behave this
way and if you watch my uh the the show
that we did with uh Patrick that David
up in Fort Lauderdale when I was on
valuetainment they did the live show in
front of about three four hundred people
I'm on with Rudy Rudy's obviously the
Trump guy I'm The Descent of this guy
and I kept saying to Rudy the attacks
aren't working the attacks aren't
working and lo and behold about two days
later Trump stopped the the Rhino
globalist attacks because they were so
obviously not true but he's throwing out
the kitchen saying Soros loves him uh
you know like all of this stuff it's
like dude it's not working and if if in
your quest for power if you're in your
quest for it has to be me again I'm
willing to do everything I can to
destroy the best guy that we got look I
think deep down even the people that are
supporting Trump hardest right now they
know DeSantis is is the better candidate
but they're showing a certain degree of
loyalty there there is something to be
said for that there really is
um but there is a younger stronger more
disciplined more effective version out
right now and I just think I think if if
DeSantis sticks to that that that
competency that Clarity that
communication doesn't play the games and
I think he's I think he's disciplined
enough to do it I think if he does that
Trump's going to kind of spin out of
control but again for the Trump people
watching this and for for old Don
himself if he's watching this there is
an out here man like this doesn't have
to be we're going to burn down the whole
thing it could literally be boy you know
what I guess things changed a little bit
and you know I was a little crazy with
the Santas but actually he is a good guy
it's just politics let's go win this
thing let's get rid of the radical left
in the Democrats wouldn't that be
something and then you're the freaking
hero like you still can be the king
maker there's such an obvious out for
Trump and I want him to know that I
think he should know that and hopefully
he does know that uh Joe says what is
your vote in the famous Infamous dad
shoes you know the ones the white New
Balance shoes with the blue trim that
turn green by the end of the summer yay
or nay I believe my brother who is a
three-time father has those shoes and my
dad certainly has those shoes I do not
have those shoes uh I usually wear more
sort of sporty Nike you know Air Max
kind of things however
and I got in a little trouble for it
this weekend you guys know I'm wearing
them right now you guys know I love my
uh I love my sliders right I love my
sliders I wear these things all the time
they're comfortable you know if I'm just
out and about I'm going to the
supermarket whatever this weekend I
almost walked out of the house while
wearing socks with the sliders with
shorts and David said to me what are you
doing you cannot be seen like that
someone could take a picture of you but
we used to live in West Hollywood where
there were these Russian immigrants and
they were always walking around with
socks and Sliders I thought these people
seemed very comfortable
but anyway I guess it's big faux pas but
is there anything more dad-like socks
and flip-flops I know I'm gonna I'm
gonna get more hate mail for this show
than anything we've done lately even
when I accidentally said The Tib Scott
was gay which again we have no evidence
of Optimus 147 says so first there was a
war on men or toxic masculinity and now
there's a war on women is it some sort
of payback that's actually hilarious
right it's all so stupid we're in a
giant gender War by a bunch of people
who pretty much just can't get laid like
that's what it seems like it all comes
down to if you can't get laid like a
normal person like everyone used to go
out there and get laid however you had
to do it then you just attack everyone
else for their genitals pretty much it's
all so dumb Kyle says would you consider
interviewing Janet Nunez who's the
lieutenant governor of Florida if
DeSantis is elected president she will
succeed DeSantis as governor of Florida
and finish his term I feel like she has
understandably kept a somewhat low
profile the administration and I'm
curious on how she would continue to
this is Legacy you know I've met her a
couple times at events in the last year
and a half or so and I did do a very
brief interview with her on Election
night if you remember we were at the
DeSantis Campaign Headquarters really a
big party uh because they knew what was
going to happen uh for uh back in
November and I interviewed a couple
people just in the room there it was a
little hard to hear because there was so
much cheering and screaming look I like
her a lot I think she's really effective
she strikes me as like deeply kind of
pleasant and nice I think she would keep
the agenda going my guess is this
assuming the Santos announces in the
next couple days I think they're going
to do more usually when when a senator
or Governor or whatever mayor announces
they're just like all in on the run and
that's it now he closed up the
legislative session here but I have a
feeling that they will start seating the
ground with the types of people that
should be leading Florida effectively I
think there's a really strong Machinery
here I think Jeanette Nunez would be a
great Governor I think there's plenty of
other people that maybe could jump into
that role it seems to be fairly obvious
that Bayern battles has a huge future in
front of him and and plenty of other
people so I think Florida will remain
free and look if Trump becomes the
nominee and or president and we're left
with DeSantis round two I think we'll be
okay too so Florida is going to be just
fine guys if you have not subscribed
already please do it reubenreport
rumble.com reubenreporter
reubenreport.com locals uh as I said
there is no post game show today because
I have to go somewhere
so we will not have a show tomorrow
but I will be back on Friday
okay see you later
if you're listening to this on audio I'm
winking right now goodbye
[Music]
thank you